[Musique]
mangin tous ravis de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de présidentielle
360 voici les titres
onze candidats pour un débat inédit ce
soir à la télévision ils auront quinze
minutes chacun pour convaincre
l'exercice peut s'avérer périlleux pour
les favoris du scrutin
marine le pen et emmanuel macron qui
seront au centre de toutes les attaques
analyse dans cette édition quel avenir
pour l'espace schengen une commission d'
enquête du sénat rendu ses conclusions
elle dénonce des points de contrôle
inefficace et des fichiers de sécurité
inopérant le détail à suivre en plein
débat sur la surpopulation carcérale
ancien sénateur jean rené lecerf a remis
au ministre de la justice
un livre blanc sur les prisons pour lui
il faut renoncer aux grandes structures
et privilégier les alternatives à
l'incarcération
on en parle dans un instant et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
édition en direct hashtag présidentielle
à 360 alors que la pression migratoire
aux portes de l'europe ne faiblit pas un
rapport du sénat pointent les failles
dans la sécurité de l'espace schengen et
préconise de réintroduire le contrôle
aux frontières intérieures
un diagnostic contesté par les sénateurs
socialistes mnjs aussi renforcer les
contrôles sans dénaturer le principe de
libre circulation
une équation difficile pour la
commission d'enquêté sénatoriale sur
l'avenir de schengen 32 propositions
ressort du rapport comme rester à 22
pays et gelé l'élargissement jusqu'à
nouvel ordre ou réintroduire des
contrôles aux frontières intérieures en
cas de menace pour la sécurité du
territoire dans un contexte de crise
migratoire et de risque terroriste
accrue la commission prône une plus
grande vigilance
il faut renforcer sur une gaine c'est à
dire dans les contrôles qui doivent être
faits pour rentrer sur le territoire
schengen voire même pour se déplacer à
l'intérieur du territoire schengen et
cela nous sommes à ce jour trop faible
il faut donc aller beaucoup plus loin et
beaucoup plus vite notamment dans la
mise en place du fichier pnr qui permet
de contrôler les passagers de vols
aériens
le rapport propose même d'étendre ce
dispositif aux transports terrestres et
maritimes et d'harmoniser les systèmes
de recherche informatique euros
p1 pour un meilleur suivi des voyageurs
le rapport ne fait pas l'unanimité les
socialistes se sont abstenus
mais sont d'accord sur plusieurs points
comme le renforcement des frontières
extérieures et la création d'un corps de
gardes frontières européens unique
principal point de tension le projet
d'installation de hotspots dans des
états hors schengen pour traiter les
demandes d'asile
le groupe socialiste refuse cette
externalisation c'est impossible en
droit français
l'asie ne peut-être de demander que sur
le territoire de la république et par
extension sur le territoire européen
c'est l'objet aussi de conventions
internationales et puis ces hotspots
on va les mettre tous à l'extérieur dans
des pays sûrs ou non sur quelles
garanties
y aura-t-il pour la sécurité la liberté
et la dignité des personnes qui s'y
trouvent en permettant la libre
circulation des personnes schengen est
un atout sur le plan économique son
durcissement aurait un coût le
rétablissement des contrôles permanents
en france coûterait à l'état un milliard
et demi d'euros par an c'est un des
enjeux de cette campagne présidentielle
la politique pénale et carcérale de la
france alors qu'un nouveau record de
détenus vient d'être enregistrée jean
rené lecerf ancien sénateur a remis au
garde des sceaux un livre blanc sur les
prisons il propose de nouvelles
alternatives à l'incarcération samia de
chiens cinquante-huit mille six cents
places de prison pour 68400 détenus la
france bat un nouveau record avec une
densité carcérale de 118% un taux qui
grimpe à 142 % dans les maisons d'arrêt
dans son livre blanc remis aujourd'hui
au ministère de la justice
la commission sur l'immobilier
pénitentiaire approuve le programme de
construction de 33 nouvelles maisons
d'arrêt mais son président prévient plus
il y a de prison plus il y a deux
détenus il préconise avant tout
d'encourager les alternatives à
l'incarcération
appliquons la loi sur la contrainte
pédales et on trouvera effectivement des
solutions en termes d'alternatives à
l'incarcération en terme d'aménagement
de peine qui permettront de ne mettre en
détention que des personnes qui doivent
passer effectivement par la case prison
dans son livre blanc la commission sur
l'immobilier pénitentiaire et mes 24
grandes propositions comme l'affectation
direct des courtes peines au quartier de
préparation à la sortie sans passer par
la case maison d'arrêt proposé 5
d'activité par jour à chaque détenu ou
encore associer les collectivités
territoriales et la société civile à la
gestion des prisons à travers des
réunions annuelles autour des préfets
aussi longtemps que la société civile ne
s'intéressera pas assez prison les
prisons resteront effectivement une
humiliation comme disait le cdh apprend
la république
il faut que les maires notamment des
communes d'implantation et tous les
maires pour le travail d'intérêt général
participe pour mettre en oeuvre les
propositions de la commission le
ministère de la justice veut faire voter
le plus rapidement possible une loi de
programmation d'un milliard d'euros sur
cinq ans pas une minute ne peut être
perdu
l'objectif doit être une présentation
par le garde des sceaux alors en
fonction et un vote de cette loi de
programmation à la fin de cette année
2010 est dans les prochaines semaines le
nombre de détenus pourrait monter à 70
milles le ministère veut agir vite
mais la suite dépendra du prochain
occupant de la place vendôme
c'est jeudi que doit se réunir un bureau
national du parti socialiste à l'ordre
du jour est le cas de manuel vals
certains élus réclament son exclusion
après l'annoncé de son ralliement
emmanuel macron pas du goût de son
ancien directeur de campagne lors de la
primaire le sénateur socialiste didier
guillaume il l'a dit ce matin à elodie
grégoire on écoute le candidat de la
primaire benoît hamon qui fait ça qui
fait sa campagne à d'autres élus qui ont
fait un autre choix bon mais c'est comme
ça c'est regrettable mais c'est pas le
moment de
de remettre de l'huile sur le feu
maintenant ce qui compte c'est que après
le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous soyons tous là pour
faire vivre une nouvelle majorité
exclure qu'ils ne visaient pas
d'explosion il n'y a pas eu d'effusion
pour ceux qui ont déposé une motion de
censure pendant le quinquennat n'y a pas
d'exclusion maintenant on est à 15 jours
du ou trois semaines du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle l'heure n'est
pas à se poser de questions moi je
cherche pas à faire diversion il faut
avancer
et puis le canard enchaîné révèle qu'une
enquête préliminaire a été ouverte par
le parquet de lille pour soupçon
d'emplois fictifs ou au front national à
la région nord-pas de calais c'est un
premier débat à onze inédit dans
l'histoire de la vème république on va
bien sûr en débattre des enjeux
politiques de cet exercice avec mes
invités mais avant cela voyez comment il
va se dérouler avec les explications de
jean raby ils seront donc 11 à se
partager le plateau du débat pour 3
heures 30 d'émissions sur bfmtv ses news
placé en arc de cercle
selon le résultat d'un tirage au sort
les candidats devront donc se tasser
pour tenir moins d'un mètre séparant les
différents pupitres le temps de parole
des prétendants à l'elysée sera lui
aussi compté une minutes d'introduction
15 minutes de réponse et de débats et
enfin une minute pour conclure pas une
seconde de plus espèrent les
organisateurs
trois grands thèmes seront évoqués sous
forme de trois questions posées aux
candidats comment créer des emplois
comment protéger les français et comment
mettre en oeuvre votre modèle social
pas question enfin de permettre aux
candidats d'être informés par leur
entourage les portables seront donc
interdits
un exercice inédit et qui pourrait bien
être le seul sous cette forme
france 2 ayant essuyé des refus dans sa
tentative de reproduire l'exercice à
trois jours du premier tour et ce soir
public sénat vous propose dès 22h de
revivre le débat qui a opposé en 74 le
ministre des finances de l'époque valéry
giscard d'estaing au candidat de l'union
de la gauche françois mitterrand une
joute cathodique qui avait marqué les
esprits flore sauvage c'est en 1974 qui
est organisé le premier débat de
l'entre-deux-tours à l'élection
présidentielle valéry giscard d'estaing
face à françois mitterrand
une première
la télévision grâce à une idée importée
des états unis on s'est dit que ça
serait quand même bien d'essayer de
faire en france qui s'était produit en
62 aux états unis avec le fameux débat
entre nixon kelly et donc on s'est
réparti le travail sur le plateau de le
rtf l'ambiance est glaciale les deux
hommes avaient le sentiment quand même
que il jouer gros parce que d'une part
c'est le premier débat donc personne ne
savait ce que seraient les faits comment
ça se passerait et puis surtout les
sondages de premier tour les mettez
extraordinairement proche à égalité et
déjà en 74
les journalistes ont les yeux rivés sur
le chronomètre pour faire respecter les
temps de parole des deux candidats les
candidats qui s'affrontent à l'aide de
petites phrases bien choisi c'est aussi
la sphère de coeur il n'est pas
acceptable qu'il y ait une petite
catégorie de privilégiés qui sont qui
sont servis par tout vouloir en
particulier par vos lois fiscales
il avait subi intervention vous a écouté
comme je vous ai écouté avec intérêt
on est convaincu que ce qu'il faut faire
ce n'est pas ce que vous proposez
d'abord je veux dire quelque chose je
trouve toujours choquant et blessant de
s'arroger le monopole du coeur vous
n'avez pas monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur vous n'avez pas j'ai
un coeur comme le vôtre qui bat sa
cadence et qui est le mien vous n'avez
pas le monopole du coeur une phrase
restée célèbre dans l'histoire des
débats télévisés
neuf jours après valéry giscard
d'estaing est élu président de la
république
[Musique]
et pour analyser les enjeux du débat de
ce soir mes invités sur ce plateau
emmanuel rivière bonsoir vous êtes
directeur france de kantar public merci
d'être avec nous face à vous bruno
cautrès bonsoir chercheur au cnrs membre
du cevipof on vient de ré écouter avec
plaisir d'ailleurs ces échanges entre
valéry giscard d'estaing et françois
mitterrand
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre emmanuel
rivière à des attaques aussi bien ciblés
on appelle ça maintenant des punchline
est ce que vous pensez que l'exercice de
ce soir ça peut être aussi le théâtre de
répliques d'anthologie
oui ça peut l'être parce que il ya un
temps très court finalement pour chacun
des des candidats et un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont pour enjeu d'émerger et
les sous qu'on appelle les petits
candidats qui s'insurgerait d'ailleurs
de cette appellation qui estime que la
campagne ne va pas assez mis en valeur
et qui ont une occasion peut-être unique
puisqu'il n'est pas sûr qui est un 3e
débat qu'il est qui les invite de se
distinguer de faire apparaître quelque
chose et d'être ceux dont on dira demain
mais finalement c'est lui qui a créé la
surprise celui qu'on n'attendait pas
forcément
et puis il ya aussi ceux qui jouent pour
gagner et qui ayant un retard ou un
supposé retard se disent là il faut que
je marque des points ira plus tant
d'occasions que cela d'autant que il
apparaît que ces débats sont très
suivies et qu'il apparaît aussi que ces
débats sur l'impact enfants qu'ils
peuvent faire bouger les lignes
on va y venir dans un instant bruno
cautrès sur l'aspect spontané
spontanéité ou préparation on imagine
que chaque candidat on l'a rappelé
quinze minutes seulement pour présenter
son programme est ce que ça laisse la
place finalement aux attaques à ces
petites phrases aussi qu'on retient
forcément de ces débats oui forcément
parce qu'on est aussi au deuxième débat
est donc les candidats savent que le
temps leur est compté aujourd'hui il
faut il faut rattraper il faut
s'affirmer pour certains il faut exister
à travers peut-être une proposition un
peu marquante ou alors à travers une
petite phrase et puis pour d'autres il
s'agit bien sûr de creuser le sillon
éventuellement de rattraper le retard
donc dans un temps très court avec onze
candidats oui bien sûr on devrait
normalement s'attendre à une
communication qui va aller chercher qui
va aller débusquer la petite phrase le
truc un peu marquant donc oui on peut
s'attendre à ça ce soir et manière à
venir c'est vrai que vous évoquiez à les
petits candidats
une appellation et il conteste
certainement on sait qu'ils vont ces 15
minutes pour convaincre ça peut encore
et bien leur permettre d'émerger dans
cette campagne c'est un débat inédit
pour une campagne qu'il est aussi c'est
compliqué de tout ça sans pour les
candidats qui ne jouent pas dans l'it
dans l'esprit des français pour la
victoire parce que c'est que cette
élection est très particulière et
beaucoup d'électeurs la voix un peu
comme une élection à un tour où il faut
absolument éviter d'avoir un second tour
dont on ne voudrait pas donc il n'y a
pas beaucoup de place et en gros pour
dire les choses clairement
depuis que pour un certain nombre
d'électeurs la présence du front
national est un pèse sur l'élection
présidentielle c'est à dire depuis 2002
il ya des logiques de vote utile qui
sont des laminoirs petits candidats
c'est-à-dire qui empêche d'avoir ce
mécanisme au premier tour on se fait
plaisir avec la certitude d'avoir au
second tour le candidat que que l'on
souhaiterait puis il cède cette logique
de vote utile finalement elle vaut pour
tout le monde c'est à dire que y compris
à un certain nombre d'électeurs qui vont
choisir l'option front national plutôt
que d'autres pour être sûr aussi d'être
d'être d'être représentés donc ce
mécanisme à deux tours il est peu
favorable à l'émergence des petits
candidats comme d'autres scrutins que
nous souhaitons et européennes par
exemple peut l'être
pas grand chose à perdre ses petits
candidats en revanche les favoris de ce
scrutin dont la fois marine le pen
emmanuel macron beaucoup ce soir
emmanuel macron qui récuse d'ailleurs en
ce statut de favori dans cette élection
c'est vrai que c'est pas très
confortable comme position maintenant on
sait que c'est pas une position
confortable parce qu emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui la trois semaines d'une
certaine manière pour se maintenir pour
pas fléchir il va falloir qu'ils
occupent l'espace en même temps il a
beaucoup occupés on l'a beaucoup vu
donc pour lui il ya un enjeu qui est
d'apparaître au fond à la fois solide
sur ses programmes sur ces propositions
est sans aucun doute de lever peut-être
quelques points d'interrogation des
électeurs ou encore sur lui les fameuses
hésitant dont on a beaucoup parlé dans
cette campagne sont finalement en nombre
encore peu assez important dans
l'électorat d'emmanuel macron donc lui
il ya un enjeu qui est d'affirmer
de se montrer comme un candidat qui va
pouvoir définitivement attirer des votes
et puis il ya d'autres candidats qu un
enjeu très important ce soir je pense en
particulier du côté de benoît hamon
benoît hamon on a vu qu'il est à la
peine démarrage de campagne
et puis même au milieu du gué de la
campagne très difficile il ya d'une
certaine manière les voilà et puis une
dernière peut être opportunité pour lui
d'essayer de réaffirmer aux yeux des
électeurs de la gauche que c'est lui le
candidat de la gauche assure emmanuel
macron emmanuel rivière est ce que c'est
le seul candidat à avoir ce problème de
volatilité de l'électorat selon vous non
la volatilité en fait elles couvrent
l'ensemble de la gauche et donc benoît
hamon a le même problème qui rassemble
des lecteurs qui sont en train de se
dire voilà quel est le le bon cheval sur
lequel sur lequel miser pour représenter
la gauche dans laquelle je me sens à
l'aise et pour cela il ya un choix entre
amont et mêlant chant et puis il ya tous
ces électeurs qui se disent de gauche
encore comment je fais pour éviter le
duel fillon le pen ils sont nombreux et
donc là il peut y avoir d'hésitation
entre amont emmanuel macron
mécaniquement quand un candidat est au
centre de l'échiquier politique et c'est
ce qui se produit pour emmanuel macron
effectivement il offre plus de
d'hésitation possible parce qu'il ya des
électeurs de droite qui hésite entre
emmanuel macron et françois fillon un
autre candidat de droite dans tout le
monde nicolas dupont aignan et puis les
électeurs de gauche qui vont hésiter
entre evans elle m'apprend et d'autres
offres la gauche donc il est placé au
coeur de l'incertitude qui veut pas dire
qu'il ya une totale volatilité non plus
parce que souvent il faut avoir l'esprit
des électeurs hésitants ils n'hésitent
pas entre les onze hésité entre deux et
parfois même ils hésitent entre aller
voter pour un candidat qui allait régler
leur paraître acceptables ou ne pas
aller voter du tout cette volatilité
cette dualité se retrouveront le disais
à l'instant entre jean luc mélenchon et
et benoît hamon serait que jean luc
mélenchon il apparaît comme l'homme en
forme est ce que vous confirmez cette
dynamique
oui dans l' enquête qu'on vient de
publier au cevipof effectivement on
confirme ce que ce que d'autres enquêtes
d'opinion ont montré ça une vraie
dynamique mélenchon est pas seulement
une dynamique en intentions de vote mais
dynamique en images regarder tout à
l'heure une un indicateur que nous avons
dans les enquêtes du cevipof qui est la
côte d'amour des différents candidats
est ce qu'on aime bien cette
personnalité et on voit que depuis
quinze jours trois semaines quelque
chose s'est passé pour
jean luc mélenchon il s'est affirmé il
s'est beaucoup affirmé dans le premier
débat
et puis dans cet électorat de gauche qui
finalement est assez hésitant qui se dit
mais finalement benoît hamon tient un
discours critiques sur françois hollande
françois hollande finalement pendant
cinq ans est ce que ça veut dire que ce
n'était pas un gouvernement de gauche
et bien cet électorat de gauche qui a un
peu perturbé il a un très bon candidat
qui communique bien qui fait une bonne
campagne c'est jean luc mélenchon donc
une vraie difficulté de fond pour benoît
hamon d'exister dans cette élection en
ayant un discours critique de gauche sur
les cinq ans qui viennent de se passer
de dire aux électeurs de gauche
et bien finalement c'était pas la gauche
qui était au pouvoir mais françois
hollande a été leader du parti pendant
onze ans donc est ce que c'est possible
comme discours et à écouter pour des
électeurs de gauche et puis sur sa route
bella jean luc mélenchon jean luc
mélenchon vous êtes d'accord il s'est
affirmé là aussi tirer les enseignements
de la campagne de 2012 oui et il
comprise d'ailleurs des déboires qu'il a
connu entre 2012 aujourd'hui notamment
des défaites au sol et fatalisme
s'étaient annoncés presque à 100% ses
chronos aussi d'une logique de vote
utile l'as rome le lecteur qui voulait
avant tout je débarrasse et nicolas
sarkozy qui sont dit finalement la
meilleure carte à jouer c'est hollande
dès le premier tour mais je crois que
jean luc mélenchon a réussi dans cette
campagne et dans ce débat une rupture
d'image qui lui est favorable
dire qu'ils y compris son image
s'améliore et chez des gens qui ne
voteront pas pour lui qui le jugent
moins agressif
moins négatif moins systématiquement en
colère qui ne l a pu paraître d'ailleurs
la manière dont lui même reformule
l'idée qu'il serait devenu quelqu'un de
plus rassurant montre bien que tout ça
est une probablement une stratégie assez
délibérée de sa part françois fillon de
ce débat que peut-il attendre le
candidat de la droite à la
présidentielle françois fillon il est
dans une situation qui est une situation
d' essayer de sauver sa peau d'une
certaine manière il a plus que quelques
jours quelques semaines du coup c'est ce
qu'il appelle le vote catalan alors
voilà je suis pas sûr qu'il ya un vote
cash et moi je pense qu'à plus tôt
peut-être une partie de l'électorat de
droite qui a été vraiment perturbée et
qui hésitent qui se dit mais finalement
est-ce qu'on va passer à côté de la
victoire qui nous était promise la
victoire semblait d'une certaine manière
presque tout fait à l'issue de la
primaire on se rappelle qu'à l'issue de
la primaire
les enquêtes d'intentions de vote
donnait un françois fillon qu'elle et
s'imposer très facilement
et puis toutes les affaires est-ce que
l'électorat de droite aujourd'hui
accepte finalement de voir lui passer
sous le nez sous les yeux la victoire
qui était attendu ça fait cinq ans que
l'électorat de droite attend sa revanche
de 2012 et donc il ya une grande
inconnue pour moi dans cette élection le
pouls point d'interrogation important
c'est de savoir si l'électorat de droite
va vouloir à la dernière minute sauver
françois fillon c'est difficile parce
qu'il a beaucoup perdu chez les
centristes
vous y croyez à cette hypothèse il va te
cacher qui permettrait de et bien
propulser françois fillon au second tour
avec emmanuel rivière un vote
alors je rebondis sur ce que dit bruno
cautrès pas forcément cacher c'est à
dire des gens qui aujourd'hui dans les
enquêtes ne disent pas je vais voter
fillon mais qui effectivement pourrait
le faire au dernier moment ils n'en sont
peut-être même pas conscients
aujourd'hui faute d'alternative mais
toute la question ainsi c'est de savoir
quelle part de l'électorat représente
encore cet électorat des républicains
qui exclut toute autre choix et c'est un
peu la difficulté pour françois fillon
savoir quels sont les gens pour qui
parmi ces électeurs potentiels considère
marine le pen comme un vote possible et
auquel cas à cause de ce qui est arrivé
à françois fillon mais pour les états
chez lui et inversement qu'est la part
de l'électorat naturel de la droite
historique qui peut voter
emmanuel macron qui du coup votre
emmanuel macron si elle continue à
penser que le comportement de françois
fillon n'a pas été aussi exemplaire
qu'il leur était espéré et en n1 comme
on est dans un contexte où le poids dans
l'échiquier politique parmi les
électeurs des deux grands partis est en
train de diminuer et paradoxalement ça
s'est aussi produit pour les
républicains alors qu'ils étaient en
opposition
c'est ça la menace pour françois fillon
il doit à la fois restaurer son image et
convaincre ses électeurs que les deux
autres ne sont pas possibles
un mot sur marine le pen aussi sa
prestation lors du premier débat
télévisé avait été jugé décevant parce
qu'elle va chercher bien à capitaliser
sur sa campagne même si un peu fragilisé
notamment en interne en ce moment où ans
que pour marine le pen l'objectif c'est
surtout de s'installer dans le deuxième
tour où elle est déjà dans le premier
tour qualifiés vainqueur du premier tour
sans aucun doute donc pour l enjeu c est
ce qu elle peut élargir sa cible à ce
qu'elle peut aller chercher des
électeurs de droite déçus par fillon est
ce qu'elle peut aller chercher des
catégories populaires qui on le sait
sont très favorables à marine le pen
mais qui peut être au premier tour son
intérêt
c'est par le programme économique delà
de la gauche c'est ce qu'elle peut aller
chercher ces catégories et est ce
qu'elle peut à la fois s'élargir vers la
droite qu'elle est très sensible un
programme beaucoup plus libéral e pl1
économique et en même temps elle est
captée c'était l'auxois populaire qui
est quand même le soc sociologique de
marine le pen donc pour elle c'est
d'être dans le deuxième tour est déjà de
s'adresser à un électorat beaucoup plus
large que son électorat le premier tour
même analyse pour vous manuel rivière
sur la prestation de marine le pen ce
soir marine le pen effectivement il faut
qu'elle maintenant qu'elle installe dans
la tête de deux français pour qui le
vote le pen représenterait encore un
vote permet de faire mal au système en
fait de faire mal à ces partis
politiques établi qu'il le voit
maintenant présidente s'est totalement
le cas de l'électorat front national qui
se reproduit sur elle avec une grande
fidélité d'une élection à l'autre très
impressionnant qui voient en elle une
présidente ça ce n'est pas le sujet ça
ne suffit pas et si on veut si elle veut
conquérir 1 et le veut la fonction au
deuxième tour il faut qu'elles rassurent
dès à présent merci beaucoup emmanuel
rivière merci à bruno cautrès méchet la
grosseur me rejoint sur ce plateau à
l'instant dont soir michel ce soir notre
invité de l'épreuve de vérité aurélie
filippetti porte-parole de benoît hamon
oui et donc nous prolongerons la
conversation que vous avez à l'instant
bien sûr sur l'enjeu du débat décisif ou
non pour benoît hamon comment est-ce
qu'il s'est préparé ces dernières heures
et puisqu'il ne risque pas
éventuellement d'être rangé demain dans
la catégorie des petits candidats s'il
décroche encore il est à 10% des
sondages également et puis il ya aussi
une actualité que nous traiterons qui
est un peu zappé aujourd'hui parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de teasing autour du débat
de ce soir c'est quand même ce
bombardements chimiques sur une ville
détenue par des rebelles en syrie et
nous demanderons et aurélie filippetti
s'il estime qu'en france notamment parmi
certains candidats à la présidentielle
il ya encore trop de complaisance pour
l'homme fort de damas merci beaucoup
michel métreau regretter c'est donc à
suivre en direct à 18h30 en attendant
retour justement sur les déclarations
des onze candidats à la présidentielle
sélectionné ce soir par les crampes ou
tard je suis le candidat de la feuille
de paye
pouvoir d'achat le candidat de cette
france qui se lève tôt donne aux
adversaires aiment tant parler mais
qu'ils ne rencontrent jamais je suis
frappé de constater que la campagne
telle qu'elle a commencé on voit des
candidats qui présentent des mesures en
matière économique sociale de santé
d'éducation de culture très bien moi
aussi j'en présenterait mais quel est
leur programme en tant que président de
la république nous vivons dans cette
malédiction de la politique française
depuis tant d'années je n'ai vu au
gouvernement je l' ai vu au parlement je
les ai vus dans l'état alors oui
maintenant ils m'attaquent en disant
tout à la fois que je suis l'héritier et
le prg est d'abord il faut choisir
l'histoire qu'on veut raconter je ne
peux pas effet deux dans la vie
politique française
on ne veut pas qu émergent des courants
nouveau on veut pas que les français
aient le choix et on les rend prisonnier
d'un dilemme soit on continue avec ceux
qui nous on tue à petit feu
soit on part au fonds national mois pour
pouvoir porter auprès des français le
choix fondamental entre le patriotisme
et le mondialisme
il faut que je sois présente au second
tour c'est essentiel sinon les français
auront le choix qu'entre 1 mondiaux 10
ans les sourires mondialistes un
mondialiste décomplexée et un
mondialiste honteux il faut que les
bulletins de vote donnent le coup de
balai qu'il est pas tous sans exceptions
dégagèrent il ya un nouveau vendre
qu'est née après résistance se dégager
il ya un combat à mener contre ceux qui
instaure leur diktat en fait sur le
monde ouvrier
1 ces grands groupes capitalistes de
l'automobile bancaire qui peuvent
décider du jour au lendemain de fermer
une usine de supprimer des emplois de
bloquer les salaires de d'augmenter le
temps de travail qui ont donc un poids
feu phénoménale sur nos vies à tous mais
à moi je dis qu'il faut les combattre il
ne faut pas se laisser faire qu'il ne
faut pas se laisser imposer ce diktat à
gauche comme jaurès et je dirais dans la
politique internationale à droite comme
de gaulle c'est de gaulle et jaurès qui
représenter ses intérêts d'une france
indépendante et une bo en france qui se
bat pour être à la fois médiateur pour
être à la fois inspirateur
en même temps éclaireur comment ça se
fait que dans ce monde là où même en
palais dans l'espace fin avant tout ce
qu'on peut voir tout ce qu'on peut
résoudre et à côté ça on voit qu'il ya
des milliards de gens qui crèvent la
dalle et puis des gens qui sont au
chômage
rien de ce qui va pas et il est assez
pas une fatalité c'est un plan
d'organisation de la société nos
adversaires redoublent d'efforts pour
multiplier jusqu'à la caricature les
manoeuvres les intox les bassesses et
les coups bas sans doute sans doute
espère-t-il ainsi nous faire taire
allez-vous laisser faire et vous les
laissez vous venez cette élection
certainement pas je demande à ceux qui
ne veulent pas aller voter à me paraît
vous de nouveau de votre droit à exister
c'est être ou ne pas être
si vous avez choisi de suivre et
continuer les seins ils vont faire le
job le job disent que le système leur
impose si vous voulez retrouver votre
pays avec sa joie d'être son molaires de
créer sa recherche sa jeunesse son
printemps
ces campagnes tc lille et même ses
banlieues alors faites
laissez vous aller suivez votre coeur je
ne fais pas pire que ce qui a été fait
depuis 25 ans
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette édition de
présidentielle 360 merci à vous de
m'avoir suivi tout de suite l'épreuve de
vérité qui reçoit ce soir aurélie
filippetti porte-parole de benoît hamon
très bonne soirée à tous et à demain
[Musique]